[Musique]
d'événements c'est super important parce
que faire attention à l'environnement je
dois être dans une de nos priorités
chacun de nous apprendre conscience de
nos impacts sur économiques et
environnementaux de toutes nos actions
au programme de ces trois jours
découvertes des secrets de l'eau
sensibilisation à la biodiversité vente
de plans de fruits et légumes ou encore
atelier création pour les plus jeunes
voilà un thème qu'on entend au quotidien
et aujourd'hui un festival qui est
présenté avec essentiellement un public
jeune et c'est vraiment un heureux
événement que de faire ce croiser
l'élection de la nouvelle présidente du
conseil départemental jeune et le
festival du parti pas c'est un symbole
fort voilà des jeunes qui se dessinent à
prendre des responsabilités et qui
participe également à cette entreprise
que de la prise de conscience de notre
développement durable et qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur à la Réunion je
tiens également à mettre en avant le
travail
total des agents du Département qui
travaillent sur cette thématique tout au
long de l'année qui arrive à nous
proposer dans un calendrier restreint un
nombre d'événements importants sur cette
thématique au sensibiliser la population
de La Réunion à ces sujets de
développement durable et de transition
écologique il est important de
vulgariser le discours et de toucher
toutes les classes et toutes les classes
d'âge et les classes sociales de notre
île pour que le message passe le mieux
au stand du département le public était
invité à découvrir une nouveauté en
réalité augmentée
donc là on est effectivement au salon
typhatipa la collectivité faite cette
année les 30 ans de politique de
préservation des espaces naturels
sensibles donc et à cette occasion il a
été décidé de proposer une carte
interactive avec des milieux naturels à
découvrir sur l'ensemble de l'île
carte interactive avec des vidéos
immersives donc là je vais vous montrer
le concept on prend son téléphone et on
va scanner le QR code et là on va vivre
une expérience
sur les milieux naturels qui sont des
milieux uniques au monde et classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité par
l'UNESCO mais vous le savez tous Alors
là je suis ici à papa je clique sur une
forêt par exemple et là on va au domaine
Archambault
vous avez la maison de Ménard chambour
et là vous avez le fœtus et on poursuit
la navigation et on a une petite vidéo
immersive qui vous présente le domaine
Archambault
donc là on peut découvrir environ 30
milieux naturels maintenant le
département part beaucoup plus loin donc
si les scolaires veulent découvrez des
milieux naturels et un dispositif qui
était mis en oeuvre qui s'appelle
dotations biodiversité qui permet aux
professeurs de créer des projets
pédagogiques avec la classe les enfants
peuvent partir dans les milieux naturels
ils peuvent aussi créer un arboretum
patrimonial espèces indigènes endémique
et mettre en oeuvre un rucher
pédagogique département finance et
différents projets dans le cadre
effectivement de sa politique de
biodiversité le festival tipatipa
accueillait enfin des conférences sur
les bouleversements climatiques
l'aquaponie mais aussi sur la
présentation du budget d'initiative
citoyenne conçue pour impliquer les
citoyens dans la construction des
politiques publiques notamment la
transition écologique et solidaire
[Musique]